-mario pellegrini era vice alcalde de la
isla de giglio cuando el costa concordia
en cayo el medio de la noche mario se
subió a un bote para ayudar en las
labores de rescate tanto producto que
eso me pregunte a mí mismo si había
hecho todo lo que podía y si realmente
había conseguido no dejar a nadie atrás
de atrás
el costa concordia un crucero de 290
metros y más de 110 mil toneladas chocó
contra una roca que provocó un corte de
35 metros en la embarcación
el capitán quería hacer una maniobra
conocida como un saludo pasar cerca de
la isla para enseñársela a los pasajeros
la evacuación comenzó una hora después
del siniestro el capitán ordenó de
manera tardía que sonaran las alarmas y
él fue uno de los primeros en abandonar
el crucero 32 personas perdieron la vida
francesco schettino fue condenado en
2015 a 16 años de cárcel por homicidio
involuntario dejando atrás la nave y un
desastre ambiental los medios italianos
lo bautizaron como el capitán cobarde'
esa noche giglio se hizo gigante las
cuatro mil doscientas personas a bordo
del costa concordia equivalían a seis
veces la población que por esos días
tenía la isla los habitantes se volcaron
a ayudar a supervivientes como kevin
este ciudadano indio afincado en italia
perdió a su hermano su cuerpo fue el
último que las autoridades encontraron
eso fue en 2014 y ahora la protección
nacional civil le rinde tributo grande o
seoane
es una emoción enorme recibir algo de
tal valor tiene un efecto enorme y
un efecto enorme costa cruceros la
matriz del costa concordia pagó una
multa de un millón de euros mientras que
es que ti no está a la espera de una
apelación ante el tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos para terminar su
condena en su casa el navío fue
reflotado y remolcado fuera de giglio en
2014 para luego ser desguazado